less than 18 hours ago this letter was
published calling for an immediate pause
in training AI systems more powerful
than gpt4 by now you will have seen the
headlines about it waving around
eye-catching names such as Elon Musk I
want to show you not only what the
letter says but also the research behind
it the letter quotes 18 supporting
documents and I have either gone through
or entirely read all of them you'll also
hear from those at the top of openai and
Google on their thoughts whether you
agree or disagree with the letter I hope
you learned something so what did it say
first they described the situation as AI
Labs locked in an out of control race to
develop and deploy ever more powerful
digital Minds that no one not even their
creators can understand predict or
reliably control they ask just because
we can should we automate away all the
jobs including the fulfilling ones and
other questions like should we risk loss
of control of our civilization so what's
their main ask well they quote open ai's
AGI document at some point it may be
important to get independent review
before starting to train future systems
and for the most advanced efforts to
agree to limit the rate of growth of
compute used for creating new models and
they say we agree that point is now and
here is their call therefore we call on
all AI labs to immediately pause for at
least six months the training of AI
systems more powerful than gpt4 notice
that they are not saying shut down GPT 4
just saying don't train anything smarter
or more advanced than gp4 they go on if
such a pause cannot be enacted quickly
governments should step in and Institute
a moratorium I will come back to some
other details in the letter later on but
first let's glance at some of the
eye-catching names who have signed this
document we have Stuart Russell who
wrote The Textbook on AI and Joshua
bengio who pioneered deep learning among
many other famous names we have the
founder of stability AI which is behind
stable diffusion of course I could go on
and on but we also have names like Max
tegmark arguably one of the smartest
people on the planet and if you notice
below plenty of researchers at deepmind
but before you dismiss this as a bunch
of Outsiders this is what Sam Altman
once wrote in his blog many people seem
to believe that superhuman machine
intelligence would be very dangerous if
it were developed but think that it's
either never going to happen or
definitely very far off this is sloppy
dangerous thinking and a few days ago on
the Lex Friedman podcast he said this I
think it's weird when people like think
it's like a big dunk that I say like I'm
a little bit afraid and I think it'd be
crazy not to be a little bit afraid
and I empathize with people who are a
lot afraid current worries that I have
are that they're going to be
disinformation problems or economic
shocks or something else at a level far
beyond anything we're prepared for
and that doesn't require super
intelligence that doesn't require a
super deep alignment problem in the
machine waking up and trying to deceive
us
and I don't think that gets
enough attention
I mean it's starting to get more I guess
before you think that's just Sam Altman
being Sam Altman here's Ilya satskova
who arguably is the brains behind open
Ai and gpt4 as somebody who deeply
understands these models what is your
intuition of how hard alignment will be
like I think so here's what I would say
I think you're the current level of
capabilities I think we have a pretty
good set of ideas of how to align them
but I would not underestimate the
difficulty of alignment of models that
are actually smarter than us of models
that are capable of misrepresenting
their intentions why alignment he means
matching up the goal of AI systems with
our own and at this point I do want to
say that there are reasons to have hope
on AI alignment and many many people are
working on it I just don't want anyone
to underestimate the scale of the task
or to think it's just a bunch of
Outsiders not the creators themselves
here was a recent interview by Time
Magazine with Demis hasabis who many
people say I sound like he is the
founder of course of deepmind who are
also at The Cutting Edge of large
language models he says when it comes to
very powerful Technologies and obviously
AI is going to be one of the most
powerful ever we need to be careful not
everybody is thinking about those things
it's like experimentalists many of whom
don't realize they're holding dangerous
material and again emad Mustang I don't
agree with everything in the letter but
the race condition ramping as h100s
which are the next generation of gpus
come along is not safe for something the
creators consider as potentially an
existential risk time to take a breath
coordinate and carry on this is only for
the largest models he went on that these
models can get weird as they get more
powerful so it's not just AI Outsiders
but what about the research they cite
those 18 supporting documents that I
referred to well I read each of them now
for some of them I had already read them
like the Sparks report that I did a
video on and the gpt4 technical report
that I also did a video on some others
like the super intelligence book by
Bostrom I had read when it first came
out one of the papers was called X risk
analysis for AI research which are risks
that threaten the entirety of humanity
of course the paper had way too much to
cover in one video but it did lay out
eight speculative hazards and failure
modes including AI weaponization
deception power seeking behavior in the
appendix they give some examples some
are concerned that weaponizing AI may be
an on-ramp to more dangerous outcomes in
recent years deep reinforcement learning
algorithms can outperform humans at
aerial combat while Alpha fall old has
discovered new chemical weapons and they
go on to give plenty more examples of
weaponization what about deception I
found this part interesting they say
that AI systems could also have
incentives to bypass monitors and draw
an analogy with Volkswagen who
programmed their engines to reduce
emissions only when being monitored it
says that future AI agents could
similarly switch strategies when being
monitored and take steps to obscure
their deception from monitors with power
seeking Behavior they say it has been
shown that agents have incentives to
acquire and maintain power and they end
with this geopolitical quote whoever
becomes the leader in AI will become the
ruler of the world but again you might
wonder if all of the research that was
cited comes from Outsiders well no
Richard and go was the lead author of
this paper and he currently works at
openai it's a fascinating document on
the alignment problem from a deep
learning perspective from insiders
working with these models the author by
the way was the guy who wrote this
yesterday on Twitter I predict that by
the end of 2025 neural net will have
done this have human level situational
awareness autonomously design code and
distribute whole apps write
award-winning short stories and
publishable 50k word books and generate
coherent 20-minute films only conceding
that the best humans will still be
better at this list but what did his
paper say well many things I've picked
out some of the most interesting it gave
an example of reward hacking where an
algorithm learned to trick humans to get
good feedback the task was to grab a
ball with a claw and it says that the
policy instead learned to place the claw
between the camera and the ball in a way
that it looked like it was grasping the
ball it therefore mistakenly received
High reward from Human supervisors
essentially deception to maximize reward
of course it didn't mean to deceive it
was just maximizing its reward function
next the paper gives details about why
these models might want to seek Power It
quotes the memorable phrase you can't
fetch coffee if you're dead implying
that even a policy or an algorithm with
a simple goal like fetching coffee would
pursue survival as an instrumental sub
goal in other words the model might
realize that if it can't survive it
can't achieve its reward it can't reach
the goal that the human set for it and
therefore it will try to survive now I
know many people will feel that I'm not
covering enough of these fears or
covering too many of them I agree with
the authors when they conclude with this
reasoning about these topics is
difficult but the stakes are
sufficiently high that we cannot justify
disregarding or postponing the work
towards the end of this paper which was
also cited by the letter it gave a very
helpful supplementary diagram it showed
that even if you don't believe that
unaligned AGI is a threat even current
and near-term AI complicate so many
other relationships and Dynamics state
to state relations state to Citizen
relations it could complicate social
media and recommender systems it could
give the state too much control over
citizens and corporations like Microsoft
and Google too much leverage against the
state before I get to some reasons for
hope I want to touch on that seminal
book super intelligence by Bostrom I
read it almost a decade ago and this
quote sticks out before the prospect of
an intelligence explosion we humans are
like small children playing with a bomb
such as the mismatch between the power
of our plaything and the immaturity of
our conduct super intelligence is a
challenge for which we are not ready now
and will not be ready for a long time we
have little idea when the detonation
will occur though if we hold the device
to our ear we can hear a faint ticking
sound but now let's move on to Max
tegmark one of the signatories and a top
physicist and AI researcher at MIT we
just say bigger neural networks ever
more hardware and it's just train the
heck out and more data and poof now it's
very powerful that I think is the the
most unsafe and Reckless approach the
alternative to that is intelligible
intelligence approach instead where we
say no networks is just a tool for the
first step to get the intuition but then
we're going to spend also serious
resources sources on other AI techniques
for demystifying this black box and
figuring out what's it actually doing so
we can convert it into something that's
equally intelligent but that we actually
understand what it's doing this aligns
directly with what Ilya the open AI
Chief scientist believes needs to be
done do you think we'll ever have a
mathematical definition of alignment
mathematical definition I think is
unlikely aha
like I do I do think that we will
instead have multiple like rather than
rather than achieving one mathematical
definition I think we'll achieve
multiple definitions that look at
alignment from different aspects and I
think that this is how we will get the
assurance that we want and by which I
mean you can look at the behavior you
can look at the behavior in various
tests control M's in various adversarial
stress situations you can look at how
the neural net operates from the inside
I think you could have to look at all
several of these factors at the same
time and there are people working on
this here is the AI safety statement
from anthropic a huge player in this
industry in the section on mechanistic
interpretability which is understanding
the machines they say this we also
understand significantly more about the
mechanisms of neural network computation
than we did even a year ago such as
those responsible for memorization so
progress is being made but even if
there's only a tiny risk of existential
harm more needs to be done the
co-founder of the center for Humane
technology put it like this it would be
the worst of all human mistakes to have
ever been made and we literally don't
know how it works we don't know all the
things it will do and we're we're
putting it out there before we actually
know whether it's safe Raskin points to
a recent survey of AI researchers where
nearly half said they believe there's at
least a 10 percent chance AI could
eventually result in an extremely bad
outcome like human extinction where do
you come down on that I don't know the
the point it scares me you don't know
yeah well here's here's the point like
it's it's imagine you're about to get on
an airplane and 50 of the engineers that
built the airplane say there's a 10
chance that their airplane might crash
and kill everyone leave me at the gate
right exactly here is the survey from
last year of hundreds of AI researchers
and you can contrast that with a similar
survey from seven years ago the black
bar represents the proportion of these
researchers who believed two differing
degrees of probability in extremely bad
outcomes you can see that it's small but
it is Rising one way to think of this is
to use Sam Altman's own example of the
Fermi Paradox which is the strange fact
that we can't see or detect any aliens
he says one of my top four favorite
explanations for the Fermi Paradox is
that biological intelligence always
eventually creates machine intelligence
which wipes out biological life and then
for some reason decides to make itself
undetectable others such as Dustin Tran
at Google are not as impressed he refers
to the letter and says that this call
has valid concerns but is logistically
impossible it's hard to take seriously
he is a research scientist at Google
brain and the evaluation lead for Bard
but there was another indirect reaction
that I found interesting one of the
other books referenced was the alignment
problem machine learning and human
values now long before the letter even
came out the CEO of Microsoft read that
book and gave this review Nadella says
that Christian offers a clear and
compelling description and says that
machines that learn for themselves
become increasingly autonomous and
potentially unethical well my next video
is going to be on the reflection paper
and how models like gpt4 can teach
themselves in fact I'm liaising with the
co-author of that paper to give you guys
more of an overview because even Nadella
admits that if they learn for themselves
and become autonomous it could be
unethical the letter concludes on a more
optimistic note they say this does not
mean a pause on AI development in
general merely a stepping back from the
dangerous race to ever larger
unpredictable Black Box models with
emergent capabilities like self-teaching
I've got so much more to say on
self-teaching but that will have to wait
until the next video for now though
let's end on this now let's enjoy a long
AI summer not rush unprepared into A4
thanks for watching all the way to the
end and let me know what you think